[Music]
Channing is with us in Washington DC
hi Channing welcome to the Dave Ramsey
show hi Dave thank you for having me
sure what's up
so I live in DC I just recently got
married about three months ago
congratulations thank you and my husband
and I have really decided we need to be
really focused on the same page about
our finances we actually have our first
class of financial piece this evening oh
cool
but together we have probably just under
a million dollars in debt and we want to
know how I get that free without filing
bankruptcy okay how much of that is a
mortgage the mortgage about 210 so you
have $600,000 in what 335 is about in
student loans
we both have advanced degrees and then a
lot the rest is really credit cards and
personal loans so you have $300,000 of
credit cards and personal loans we have
about two three hundred thirty five
thousand student loans and about one
hundred thirty six thousand and credit
cards 44,000 personal loans and
thirty-five thousand car loans okay how
old are you I am 29 okay so what in the
world are you both on this or is this
just one of you that's completely lost
your mind well I have the majority of
the student loans and he has a majority
of the credit cards my credit card debt
is about it's not great there's not a
lot of time why does he at 29 years old
run up a hundred grand in credit card
debt
well he's 32 but I think it's one of
those things where just making really
poor financial decisions thinking be
able to pay it down as you go and it
doesn't it doesn't happen yeah okay so
you both have advanced degrees what are
your degrees in we do so
I've a degree both of our advanced
degrees no he has an MBA and I have an
advanced degree in policy I work in the
government and we actually both do now
at this point actually okay so your
household incomes what our household
income is about two thirty is there
recognition on both of your parts how
absurd the situation is yes okay
there is no I think we're both a bit
scared and want to do anything we can to
avoid okay great then I'm done I'm on
your team I can skip that step okay good
okay well you're scared and you should
be you're disgusted and you should be
yeah you're early in the early stages of
being sick and tired and being sick and
tired and you should be so here's the
thing you you guys have been living at
across the board from your education
choices to your car purchases to your
whatever you've been living at about 10x
where you're gonna get to live for the
next three years okay yep that's true
well I'm getting ready to destroy your
life as you know it because you're not
your lifestyle is considerably above
you're extremely good income and has
been for a period of time and so you've
gotten you used to spending like you're
in Congress right this is going to be
very emotional for y'all
and you're gonna have to look at it
through that lens and through a
spiritual lens or you're not going to
make it you're gonna have to not care
what anyone thinks including each other
because you're not gonna spend any money
on anything ever for the next three
years
like you've been spinning let's pretend
you're making 210 and I know you just
got married but let's pretend you've
been doing this as a couple as you went
along you've been making 210 spending
310 I'm getting ready to put you on 30
you're not gonna see the inside of a
restaurant unless it's your extra job or
you're waiting on some of the people you
work with during the day okay this is
how humbling this is going to be okay
it's gonna crush a lot of crap in your
soul that caused you to do this so the
bad news is it's gonna be really rough
the good news is it's gonna be great for
you guys relationally spiritually and
financially but you're not gonna make
the financial unless you make the
relation on the spiritual move because
that I know that I know you guys cuz I
was you guys this is exactly what I did
it's exactly what I did in my 20s I
bought and purchased a lifestyle that
was 5 to 10 X what I had yeah and it was
all because of crap inside of me that
caused me to do that right and all of
that has to be destroyed to fix it this
isn't making any sense resister brutal
yeah it's it's making a lot of sense and
it's brutal
I mean I'm warning you what's coming
okay this is not a math problem the math
problem is the symptom the problem is
what's going on inside are you guys so
the great news is you're very smart
people and if you will apply that
intellect to solving this problem as if
it were a policy problem or a business
problem you can solve the problem but
the lens by which the problem will be
solved is through spiritual contentment
godliness with contentment is great gain
translation you're gonna pull up at a
stoplight driving a piece-of-crap car
next to people that have a an income a
4th of years of the nicer
or than yours right right and you're
gonna you're not gonna care that's going
to be the cool part okay you're gonna
reach the point you don't care what
other people think and that might be a
forger knee for you or him I don't know
which one it is but some of you guys
have been you been purchasing a lot of
stuff for a lot of reasons that are
gonna change
yep they have - yeah I have - because
you're on a suicide mission right now
amazing credit cards are actually
bundled with one of those like that
relief programs where we put a pot of
money with them and then they negotiate
on your behalf so we're not even we're
not even paying on the bulk $24,000 or
the credit cards right now you're gonna
probably have to pull out of those out
of that I don't know how quickly but the
problem with those people is they don't
follow through in the administrative
layer are really really really pitiful
they're incompetent and so you're gonna
find they don't the concept of what they
pitched you is not completely bad but
you're gonna find their follow-through
is it will make your bones chill so
you're probably gonna pull back out of
those but then we're just gonna list
these debts smallest to largest
what's the home worth what's the home
life you said no what is your home worth
Oh my home worth oh I think that was he
according to hello the home is worth
about three hundred thousand okay so you
have a little bit of equity there but
not enough not going to save you so I'm
I always sell the home as the last
resort unless it's the problem and it's
not the problem here
okay ratio wise it's it's nothing
compared to this other stuff I mean you
have three hundred thirty thousand is
student loan debt two hundred thousand
on your house right it's not the problem
you know and the credit cards are almost
as much as a stinking house so it's not
the problem so I don't I don't think we
got to sell it you probably need to may
need to sell a car not gonna rush to do
that the big thing is is just this shock
to the system of your all's lifestyle
where you go from really living what we
call in Tennessee high on the hog -
you're gonna be living beans and rice
rice and beans your friends are gonna
think you've lost your mind
and your mother's gonna think you need
counseling
yeah and we actually are we live with my
parents now after we got married they
offered us to like sing with them to
help us you know with transitioning to
new life which has definitely been
helpful renting out in their house so I
put my condo up for rent when I got
engaged cuz I knew I wanted to save
money for the wedding
before we got married so I had a renter
in there the last year actually looking
for another run to release ends in a
month Oh we'll just sell it then I
thought you lived in it no we don't live
in it I'll just sell and put the 90,000
on your dead snowball yeah okay you
don't need it you're not gonna move in
it don't know you don't need no no we're
never gonna live in it it was one of
those that's yeah that was my first base
okay yeah it's gone it's gone though
then you need the 90 grand to get a jump
start on the rest of this so that just
got rid of a third of your deal okay
right so we're getting started but did
you feel that out see I just pinched you
if you feel the pinch Oh Dave's grabbing
pinching me
don't pinch me that yeah I'm gonna pinch
the lifestyle out of you and it's gonna
it's gonna change your life for the
better it's gonna change who you are in
this process is it's gonna have to it's
the way you get out you can do it though
I know I'll help you call me if you need
more help this is the Dave Ramsey show